[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à tous et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat de
reportage et d'analyse sur Public Sénat
la promesse et dans le titre donné du
sens à l'actualité grâce à l'expertise
de nos invités et voici le sommaire de
ce 12 octobre le conflit chez Total
énergie entre dans sa troisième semaine
le bras de fer continue le syndicat FO
rejoint la CGT dans le blocage des
raffineries le gouvernement déclenche la
réquisition des personnels d'un site
Esso exon mobile de Seine-Maritime et
chez les opposants politiques
l'hypothèse d'un embrasement social
inquiète les uns et ravi les autres
seuls motiv d'espoir aujourd'hui total
annonce ouvrir des négociations dans
notre débat de société ensuite plus
prospective on va partir de ce chiffre
seul
35,5 % des 60 64 ans travail en France à
quoi bon reculer l'âge de la retraite si
les entreprises continuent de se
débarrasser de leur salarié les plus
âgés le ministre du Travail fait des
propositions pour changer la donne on
les passera au crible de nos experts
tout à l'heure mais d'abord donc cette
nouvelle journée de grève dans les
raffineries et ces répercussions
politiques avec Jérôme Rabier
face aux images de file d'attente devant
les stations de service le gouvernement
tente d'activer tous les leviers comme
annoncé hier par Elisabeth borne les
premiers réquisitions arrivent dans les
raffineries bloquées l'État prend alors
sa responsabilité en demandant au préfet
de prendre des arrêtés de réquisition
dans les plus brefs délais qui devraient
être opérationnels aujourd'hui de
manière à bloquer l'accès au dépôt de
carburant de port Jérôme et améliorer la
situation dans les jours qui viennent
une fermeté gouvernementale pour les
raffineries du groupe et so excent
mobile car dans cette entreprise la
direction et une majorité le syndicat
ont signé un accord qui devait permettre
la reprise du travail mais les
représentants CGT de l'entreprise
veulent poursuivre la mobilisation en
revanche pour le groupe Total énergie le
gouvernement attend de voir l'issue des
discussions prévues entre la direction
et les syndicats du côté de la CGT on
affirme que la balle est dans le camp de
la direction on est heureux d'apprendre
que la direction est enfin repris raison
et accepte de rencontrer la CGT bien
évidemment c'est ce qu'on demande depuis
le début on est maintenant à 16ème ou
16e jour de grève on n'a pas eu de
contact avec la direction donc
évidemment ce contact arrive et on sera
présent et on discutera avec elle mais
sur le terrain le conflit sans venime
force Ouvrière a annoncé rejoindre la
CGT dans cette grève sur une partie des
sites de Total énergie bloqués le
gouvernement a déjà prévenu qu'en cas de
désaccord dans les discussions ils
n'exclut pas de nouvelles réquisitions
qui doivent permettre un retour à la
normale en quelques jours
voilà on décortique les conséquences
sociales politiques de cette grève avec
mes invités claire Chartier bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes journaliste et
essayiste Sylvain boulot bonsoir et
bienvenue historien spécialiste du
communisme des mouvements anarchistes et
de l'extrême gauche auteur du livre le
peuple du drapeau noir une histoire des
anarchistes publiée aux éditions Atlant
de j'accue également Benjamin Morel
bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
constitutionnalistes mettre le
conférence en droit public à
l'Université Paris de Panthéon Assas
Mathieu croissanto éditoris politiques
bonsoir et bienvenue Mathieu peut-être
un une première question un peu général
votre point de vue général sur cette
grève claire Chartier est-ce que vous la
trouvez justifié
c'est une question qu'on pose toujours
dans le cas de mouvement social donc
question classique mais qui se pose dans
un contexte qui ne l'est pas du tout là
on a d'abord un contexte de crise
énergétique vraiment tout à fait
exceptionnel et sur le plan politique
une majorité fragile à l'Assemblée donc
tout ça colore pas mal l'analyse moi
c'est un mouvement qui me semble cont
a bien des égards mais qui éclaire aussi
de façon très percutante une question
qui demande à être traitée vraiment
d'une toute autre manière qui est celle
du partage de la valeur alors on va
peut-être le développer donc j'ai pas
développé là mais c'est pour ça que je
là je vais faire con je pense que c'est
vraiment un mouvement qui est à la fois
intéressant lourd de conséquences et
peut-être effectivement sociale ça peut
s'embraser mais qui demande une analyse
en profondeur c'est pas un mouvement à
mon sens de de mobilisation habituelle
voilà Sylvain boulot les mots ont un
sens surtout dans les conflits sociaux
on a parlé de discussion et puis ensuite
dans cette fin d'après-midi de
négociation ouverte par Total qu'est-ce
que ça change il y a plusieurs choses
sur le fond sur la grève salarié peuvent
selon leur bon droit réclamer des
augmentations de salaire quelle que soit
la nature de leur emploi et quel que
soit la nature de leur travail c'est
sera constitutionnel qui existe au moins
depuis 1946 donc ça c'est un produit 846
non
19464 j'ai versé les dates donc ça c'est
un premier droit qui est une annéeable
en quelque sorte
après il y a une deuxième chose qui est
sont les logiques sociales et les
logiques de négociation sociale qui
existe ou qui n'existe pas dans les
différentes branches professionnelles en
l'occurrence dans dans cette branche là
il y a eu pendant un temps des
négociations sociales qui ont été rompu
et qui semble reprendre parce que les
salariés se sont mis en grève en
exigeant une répartition plus juste de
des richesses dans la mesure on est
quand même parmi les
entreprises qui font les profils les
plus importants sur la planète et donc
chez les salariés ça peut poser des
questions de juste répartition entre
action
des bénéfices en tractionnaires et
ça arrive donc ça c'est la deuxième
chose et après il y a une troisième
chose c'est l'intervention qui est
gouvernementale qui est lié au contexte
qui est la réquisition alors ça on va y
venir après la récitation je vous
donnerai la parole qui est qui est un
moyen de pression par rapport par
rapport au négociations en disant mais
on va réquisitionner si jamais il y a
pas et là on constate une troisième
chose parce que pour la dans la
Fédération CGT des de l'énergie et d'une
fédération relativement dur avec un taux
de sa mondialisation encore assez
importante avec des militants qui sont
encore on va dire marqué par
l'orthodoxie marchesienne pour certains
d'entre eux par une tradition militante
assez forte et là on a quelque chose
d'assez nouveau c'est que Force ouvrière
qui est quand même une centrale
syndicale à l'opposé de la CGT dans
cette branche là puisque on avait
affaire à des orthodoxes d'un côté
les militants de FO rejoignent
rejoignent ceux de la CGT alors que
c'est des visions assez contraires
qu'ils ont du syndicalisme donc on est
face à une revendication qui est en
train de s'étendre et qui effectivement
pose des questions sociales de fond par
rapport au partage des richesses
Benjamin Morel effectivement le je le
droit de grève on l'a dit existe en
France depuis plus de 150 ans bientôt
160 ans alors ce qui surprend ou ce qui
est nerve c'est selon le le point de vue
peut-être politique c'est cette idée de
greffe préventive ça existe quelque part
dans le dans le droit cette cette idée
là où c'est simplement voilà une
possibilité offerte au
syndicalisme et aux salariés entre
guillemets le droit n'a pas à régir ce
type de choses en plus d'ailleurs que le
politique c'est à dire que vous avez des
stratégies qui sont des stratégies
syndicales et l'objectif du droit et
bien c'est de préserver ce droit de
grève mais on le conciliant avec
d'autres droits et d'autres impératifs
on y reviendra sûrement sur les
réquisitions il y a un impératif d'ordre
public il y a également un impératif de
continuité un principe de continuité du
service public qui fait que et bien vous
pouvez modérer ce droit de grève vous
pouvez éventuellement y porter non pas
des atteintes mais en tout cas et bien
conduire à parfois et bien en encadrer
l'exercice parce que justement il y a
d'autres impératifs et donc ce faisant
même si vous faites une greffe
préventive etc et bien vous devez obéir
à un certain nombre de règles que ce
soit en termes de blocage par exemple
qui normalement dans la jurisprudence et
relativement interdite mais de manière
assez floue mais vous pouvez pas
interdire à un autre travailleur qui
voudrait lui aller travailler d'avoir
accès à son lieu de travail vous ne
pouvez pas non plus dégrader les biens
d'entreprises etc donc il y a ces
limites là et ensuite et bien vous
pouvez avoir une imitation de votre
droite grève on peut vous réquisitionner
dès lors qu'en effet il y a un principe
de contenu de service public ou de
maintien de l'ordre public on y
reviendra évidemment tout de suite sur
cette histoire de de réquisition alors
pour l'instant on l'a dit dans le sujet
de Jérôme Chartier décidé sur le le site
de Gravenchon pour Jérôme site Esso
Essonne mobile en Seine-Maritime
ça reste une menace on va dire ça comme
ça claire Chartier pour les sites de
Total énergie
sur les réquisitions est-ce que vous
diriez que c'est un choix risqué de la
part du du gouvernement
ça peut être utilisé et ça l'est de fait
politiquement comme effectivement une
surenchère de la part du gouvernement
qui fait monter la pression face à des
grévistes qui eux ne voudrait pas
diviser le pays donc c'est ce sont les
pouvoirs publics qui jouent la force
donc ça répond aussi à une demande d'une
partie de l'opinion française qui est
assez divisée d'ailleurs face à la que
je parlais tout à l'heure enfin que
j'employais le terme contestable parce
que il me semble que à cette question
donc classique là on peut apporter une
réponse effectivement assez tranchée
sinon on regarde si l'on reprend les
salaires qui ont été avancés et si on
prend les chiffres de la CGT elle-même
on a quand même un salaire moyen de ces
opérateurs de raffinerie qui tournent
autour de 3300 euros brut sans compter
donc la participation
en participation on on arrive à presque
5000 admettons que Total joue sa carte
ça a été vérifié par le monde je vais je
vais juste faire une petite incise
là-dessus qui dit que ce chiffre là de
5000 mensuels si on ajoute salaire
intéressement participation c'est pour
des des opérateurs de raffinerie qui ont
plus de 20 ans d'expérience donc voilà
donc effectivement on peut considérer en
effet bon il faut quand même rappeler
que
ce tourne autour de pour les Français
tournent autour de 3000 € et que une
infirmière de pital elle gagne en brut
1000 euros de moins donc il y a quand
même une et donc on sait que elle a une
utilité sociale donc il y a quand même
une réalité salariale dont il faut à
laquelle il faut opposer les
conséquences de ce mouvement les
conséquences c'est quoi c'est qu'on est
quand même dans un pays qui est
considérablement ralenti en raison de
cette grève on a effectivement des
entreprises au ralenti des agriculteurs
qui ne peuvent pas travailler des
transports qui ne peuvent pas
fonctionner et puis qui sont ceux qui
pâtissent le plus de ce mouvement et
bien ce sont les salariés finalement les
plus modestes qui n'ont pas les moyens
de trouver des alternatives de
travailler en télétravail chez eux ils
doivent prendre la voiture parce qu'ils
habitent en zone rurale et donc il y a
aussi un autre une autre conséquence qui
me paraît très problématique c'est celle
des soignants c'est à dire qu'il y a des
effectivement des visites qui ne peuvent
pas être effectuées parce que les
médecins les infirmières ne peuvent pas
se déplacer pour des personnes âgées qui
sont vraiment qui ont besoin de cette
aide là
des hôpitaux qui ont lancé l'alerte du
risque d'une rupture de soins donc on
l'a on revient parce que disait Benjamin
c'est qu'il y a un risque véritablement
là effectivement de rupture du service
et donc un mouvement qui se réclame d'un
de la justice sociale puisque c'est
vraiment ça le ferment de ce genre de
mobilisation et ça peut parfaitement se
comprendre encore une fois et je ne dis
pas qu'il gagne ils ont des gros
salaires c'est pas du tout ce que je dis
mais cette revendication de justice
sociale finalement elle a pour effet un
peu l'effet inverse parce que finalement
elle elle fait pâtir elle en fait bâtir
des gens qui sont soit vulnérables soit
des salariés qui roulent pas sur l'or ça
c'est le premier niveau de lecture il
faut ajouter à celui là un deuxième
parce que ça n'exonère absolument pas ce
que je viens de dire la responsabilité
du gouvernement et de Total et de total
on y reviendra un tout petit peu plus
tard Claire vous lui répondre juste
prolonger parce que c'est vrai que les
salaires peuvent sembler nettement
supérieurs aux salaires moyen enfin
après il faut voir aussi les conditions
de travail parce que c'est les 3 8 pour
la majorité
c'est pas facile c'est pas facile non
plus pour elle oui mais ça on peut pas
poser catégorie par catégorie au moins
10 ans c'est c'est les gens qui
travaillent dans l'industrie pétrolière
travaille au 38 ils ont ils sont
honoraires décalé en permanence et ainsi
de suite certainement pas un syndicat
aussi fort derrière pour mobiliser c'est
pas le problème du syndicalisme c'est le
problème des conditions de travail qui
sont en train de poser le problème du
salaire c'est pas c'est dans l'autre
mais c'est aussi le problème de
profession qui ont un pouvoir de blocage
que d'autres non pas et qui donc
finissent par pouvoir j'emploie le terme
à dessin parce qu'il peut être
provocateur pour certains pouvoir
paraître à une partie de l'opinion
française comme des privilégiés
finalement comme
je suis très partagé sur sur cette
affaire là parce que opposé les salaires
des uns des autres engendre total il y a
plus pauvre que vous c'est pas le sujet
à mes yeux c'est pas parce qu'il y a
plus pauvre que qui pourrait pas
demander une augmentation d'autant que
la situation dont il faut prendre en
compte c'est qu'il travaille pour Total
un groupe bien sûr
dans le PDG a vu sa rémunération
augmenter de 50% engranger des bénéfices
colossaux qui vient de verser un
dividende en avance à ses actionnaires
de quelques 2,6 milliards d'euros si si
ma mémoire est bonne donc que des
salariés d'une entreprise
ultra profitable dont le management
s'octroi des rémunérations
ultra profitables demande sa part du
gâteau je vois pas au nom de quoi on
leur dirait oui mais attention il y a
plus le pauvre que vous non
entreprise particulière c'est aussi la
responsabilité totale qui est manifeste
de pas vouloir ou de ne pas avoir su
déminer en amont ce sujet après il y
avait des négociations qui étaient plus
au 15 novembre manifestement ça n'a pas
marché donc j'ai un peu on peut on peut
jeter la pierre sur sur la CGT et je
pense que les temps sont bien partagé on
peut aussi dire on peut aussi dire qu'on
est dans une entreprise particulière par
ailleurs dernière chose le gouvernement
va cessé de dire depuis l'été aux
entreprises augmenter les salaires
augmenter les salaires et augmenter est
intéressant parce que il y a des enjeux
total en disant allez je vous donne la
parole Benjamin Morel et ensuite c'est
sans doute l'erreur de communication
majeure de la CGT dans cette affaire
c'est à dire que quand vous voulez
remporter une grève entre guillemets
vous avez deux ressources la ressource
blocage et là on est fait la CGT chimie
dans le secteur de raffinerie
aujourd'hui à une capacité de blocage
qui est indéniable et dont elle fait de
la démonstration mais il y a ensuite
vous avez l'opinion publique si votre
blocage n'est pas populaire que vous
perdez la bataille de l'opinion ça
devient très compliqué or là en effet
les salaires qui ont fuité etc font que
probablement à ce stade là la CGT a
perdu la bataille de l'opinion la force
des syndicats en Grande-Bretagne qui
aujourd'hui lance des grèves c'est de
dire bah nous faisons nous faisons grève
mais nous faisons grève pour l'ensemble
des salaires et là c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui et peut-être que Sylvain
laborera mais le caractère très
fragmenté de la CGT Martinez et
particulièrement inaudible pour ne pas
dire totalement mythique depuis quelques
jours et bien fait que ce combat qui est
un combat sectoriel et restait un combat
sectoriel alors que du point de vue de
la communication politique la CGT avait
tout intérêt le généraliser elle tente
de le faire aujourd'hui maintenant elle
tente notamment
un mouvement dans les centrales
nucléaires dans certaines centrales
nucléaires
ils essayent d'élargir le propos en
disant qu'ils se battent pour pour les
salaires
pour leur propre salaire et d'ailleurs
ils en ont le droit et ils en ont le
droit et ils en ont le droit chemin
après c'est ça pose la question des
mouvements sociaux d'une manière
générale à savoir que là on rentre
visiblement dans une nouvelle phase
qu'on avait pas vu depuis quelques
décennies d'habitude on a deux types de
grève des grèves défensifs pour pour
défendre son salaire défendre son statut
et des grèves offensives qui sont pour
une augmentation de salaire une
amélioration des conditions de vie là
pour le coup on est pour on change de
paradigme pour ce que pour une des
premières fois depuis des décennies on
est dans une grève qui est vous partagez
des fruits de la croissance vous
partagez les fruits de la richesse c'est
pas toujours pour la même chose et on
n'est pas dans attention on va vous
supprimer à vos votre retraite ça va
peut-être arriver un peu plus tard mais
c'est pas encore le cas pour l'instant
donc on est on a ce paradigme on a un
deuxième paradigme moi qui me semble que
j'ai souligné tout à l'heure et qui me
semble vraiment important c'est que
c'est pas uniquement la CGT maintenant
c'est la CGT puisse faire plus fort
sourire enfin la CGT est Force Ouvrière
avec des des perceptions et des
histoires syndicales complètement
différentes voire complètement opposé et
là justement il y a il y a quelque chose
qui est nouveau qui est en train de se
passer qui existe qui a pas existé
depuis plusieurs décennies également
c'est cette unité d'action entre deux
centrales qui alors qui sont retrouvés
contre la réforme des retraites mais qui
est en général sur les grèves offensives
étaient assez
[Musique]
point de vue humain c'est après ce qu'on
a connu avec le covid et tout ça ça fait
beaucoup ça fait beaucoup mais c'est pas
moi de le dire ni à vous Guillaume c'est
au tribunaux de de le dire en tous les
cas si le gouvernement veut mettre en
place et réquisition ça ira certainement
devant les tribunaux j'imagine en tous
les cas et c'est eux qui décideront
rapidement d'ailleurs ça se peut se
faire très vite s'il y a effectivement
un vrai motif pour pour actionner ces
réquisitions Benjamin Morel il y a eu
des précédents notamment on se souvient
d'octobre 2010 Nicolas Sarkozy on est en
plein mouvement sur sur les retraites
alors le secrétaire général de la CGT
feat Partners disait que la France avait
été condamnée devant
l'Organisation internationale du travail
on a vérifié cet après-midi ça n'a pas
été jusqu'à la condamnation il y a une
saisine mais il y a pas eu de
condamnation il y a eu on va dire des
reproches faits à la gestion de de ce
conflit par la France mais pas de
condamnation pour être bien précis c'est
on est dans quel cadre légal avec la
réquisition alors déjà il faut voir
qu'il y a deux réquisitions possibles
soit vous avez une réquisition au niveau
national ça implique de passer par un
si vous n'avez pas de pétrole dans votre
voiture de police si vous n'avez pas de
pétrole dans votre bus scolaire il y a
un problème de continuité du service
public en règle générale quand on porte
atteinte au droit de grève on voit ça de
manière assez régulière c'est dans les
grands services publics parce que il y a
ce principe de continuité du service
public lorsque vous avez des transports
qui sont à l'arrêt on va organiser un
service minimum là on est dans une
entreprise privée donc c'est le problème
ici certes des répercussions sur les
services publics mais bon le problème
ici c'est qu'on est face à une
entreprise privée et donc par définition
le cadre est beaucoup plus ambigu
beaucoup plus compliqué il faut vraiment
que vous arriviez à prouver que soit la
continuité du service public soit
l'ordre public et troublé le problème
entre guillemets c'est que
fondamentalement
et bien vous avez dans le cadre de cette
entreprise privée
des salariés qui ont le droit d'exercer
leur droit de grève et donc dans quelle
mesure vous cassez la grève et dans
quelle mesure vous assurez la continuité
du service public ça la réponse en
termes de jurisprudence c'est assez
simple d'abord et bien il faut que vous
arriviez à montrer que l'entreprise est
essentielle le gouvernement d'un point
de vue juridique fait une grosse erreur
en faisant des réquisitions SEO et pas à
Total parce qu'en réalité le
gouvernement l'argument du gouvernement
si je l'ai bien compris c'est de dire
d'un côté les associations les
négociations avancent de l'autre elle
n'avance pas ce n'est pas au
gouvernement d'être l'arbitre de
l'avancée des négociations le
gouvernement en fait
le gouvernement doit dire est-ce que
c'est essentiel pour la continuité du
service public et l'ordre public ou pas
l'avancée des négociations n'a rien à
voir dans l'affaire sinon vous
intervenez dans la marge de négociation
des salariés et donc là il y a une
fragilité juridique lorsqu'on est
peut-être pardon nous interrompre mais
ce qui s'est passé chez on l'a dit dans
le sujet déjà moi habillé chez Esso exo
mobile c'est qu'il y a eu un accord
salarial signé lundi mais au niveau du
groupe Accor qui a été par deux
syndicats qui sont majoritaires dans le
groupe Accor qui n'est pas validé ou qui
est dénoncé par la CGT localement dans
la raffinerie voilà et donc alors je dis
pas que ça justifie la réquisition mais
en tout cas politiquement on peut on
peut comprendre la la réflexion qui a
été menée par Isabelle borne et son
gouvernement politiquement on peut
comprendre en effet la réflexion mais du
point de vue purement juridique que vous
ayez une centrale syndicale ou quelques
salariés qui décident de faire grève le
droit de grève et le même si vous voulez
donc là fondamentalement il peut y avoir
un problème et il y a une fragilité
juridique dans ses décisions du
gouvernement que le gouvernement a
lui-même créé l'autre limite en matière
de réquisition c'est qu'en réalité vous
ne réquisitionnez comme il s'agit pas de
briser la grève vous ne réquisitionnez
que justement pour assurer l'ordre
public et la continuité du service
public ce qui implique donc ça veut dire
que ça règle pas la question de le
service des milliers ou des dizaines ou
des centaines de milliatomistes qui
passent deux heures ou 3 heures et
essayer de trouver si vous prenez le
métro en période de grève ou si vous
prenez le train en période de grève vous
savez que le service minimum dans les
transports c'est pas le service normal
et donc là en effet ce n'est pas
vraiment la fin du problème avec cette
réquisition on va ensuite ouvrir un
chapitter un peu plus politique vous
essayer du rapprochement Force Ouvrière
CGT dans le mouvement des raffineries
totales est-ce que la décision du
gouvernement a pu faire office un peu de
chiffon rouge et expliquer ce cette
radicalisation en tout cas c'est de se
durcissement
certainement puisque c'est il faut
garder à l'esprit l'arrière fond qui va
être beaucoup plus général qui risque de
nous occuper dans les semaines à venir
c'est la réforme des retraites où là il
y a un rapprochement enfin il y a même
plus qu'un rapprochement il y a même une
un front unique syndical qui va de l'une
ça sfdt jusqu'à la CGT pour refuser les
propositions actuelles du gouvernement
donc il y a des conflits sociaux qui
risquent aussi d'exploser où et on va
retrouver une des unités d'action je dis
bien des unités d'action syndicales pas
des unités syndicales où on risque de se
retrouver à certains dans un certain
nombre de fois l'ensemble des des
fédérations syndicales ou des
confédérations syndicales ensemble dans
des moteurs de grève compte tenu de la
façon dont le gouvernement est en train
de dire on va négocier mais de toute
manière on vous impose un nombre de
enfin on vous impose les principales
décisions qui là encore ça repose ce
problème du du
des réquisitions puisque on est dans
l'ABS enfin danse un état qui est
squeeze les partenaires sociaux et ce
qui squeeze les négociations sociales
qui normalement devrait avoir lieu
uniquement entre patronat et et
représentant des salariés alors
justement ça pose la question vous vous
offrez la transition tout trouver pour
pour donner la parole à Mathieu vous
voulez revenir sur les alors là on
élargit encore évidemment sur les
relations tendues entre Emmanuel Macron
et les syndicats comment les qualifier
tiens mais c'est l'histoire d'un
rendez-vous manqué devenu dialogue de
sourds sur le papier tout semblait
pourtant réuni quand Emmanuel Macron a
gravi les marches du pouvoir en 2017
parce que le jeune président il aimait
se décrire comme un enfant du rocardisme
on a cru un peu vite qu'il serait à
l'image de son mentor donc Michel Rocard
de la deuxième gauche c'est à dire celle
de la négociation versus celle de la
confrontation celle de la négociation
voilà je le disais celle du contrat
plutôt que celle de la loi bref qu'il
donnerait en gros toute sa place au
dialogue social pour pour mener ses
réformes et puis le suspense ça dure en
fait très très peu de temps parce que
trois mois après son annexion des
syndicats ont découvert un petit matin
le projet de réforme du Code du travail
par ordonnance je devais être choisi de
le faire de cette façon là en fait le
tour de la relation entre Emmanuel
Macron et syndicat a été donné ce
jour-là c'était le 30 août 2017 ça n'a
pas changé depuis ce qui relève de la
puissance publique peut faire l'objet
d'information et de concertation mais
pas de négociation a confié plus tard
Emmanuel Macron un journaliste pourquoi
cette cette méfiance vis-à-vis des
syndicats mais en fait parce qu'Emmanuel
Macron les juge à la fois trop faibles
trop peu représentatif et puis trop peu
fiable il a jamais cru au corps
intermédiaire parce qu'il est persuadé
depuis son élection en 2017 que
justement son élection elle vaut blanc
simple pour appliquer son idée et ses
programmes ces idées sont et son
programme le macronisme en fait il s'est
construit comme un combat contre les
rentes pour le chef de l'État le
syndicalisme en est devenu une avec
Sébastien son corporatisme son passéisme
pense-t-il autant d'obstacles à la
grande transformation de la société
française qui l'appelait de ses vœux en
2017 et qu'il appelle encore aujourd'hui
du coup le président de la République a
pas fait dans le détail il s'est mis dos
à dos là CGT Force Ouvrière on en
parlait mais aussi les syndicats les
plus réformistes au premier rang
desquels évidemment la CFDT qui continue
de lui en vouloir aujourd'hui on a
entendu je sais pas si vous souvenez en
septembre Laurent Berger le patron de la
CFDT reproché à Emmanuel Macron de voir
les guillemets leur marché sur la gueule
c'était une erreur oui à l'évidence
c'était une erreur qu'il paiera cache
d'ailleurs évidemment au moment des
gilets jaunes tout le monde s'en
souvient parce que là il se retrouve
bien désemparé en cherchant en vain des
interlocuteurs le nom de Macron et qu'il
continue de payer cher aujourd'hui alors
dans une période ne dispose plus qu'une
majorité relative au Parlement
parce qu'aujourd'hui le chef de l'État a
compris qu'il ne pouvait plus réformer
tout seul mais il est il semble dans
l'incapacité de passer de la théorie à
la pratique et le naturel revient vite
au galop un jour il tend la main au
premier temps plus de dialogue le
lendemain il tape du point sur la table
pour dire c'est comme ça et pas
autrement un jour il appelle les
syndicats à faire preuve de
responsabilité le lendemain il les
oublie il les méprisent où il les
cornerise résultat ni l'exécutif ni les
syndicats ni les réformes surtout n'en
sortent grandit par son obstination et
son incapacité à se remettre en cause le
président est devenu lui-même un des
rouages de ces blocages français qu'il
dénonçaient eu jadis c'est quand même un
comble effectivement claire Chartier on
sait qu'Emmanuel Macron a reproché à son
gouvernement un peu de retard à
l'allumage essayer de reprendre
reprendre la main comment vous
l'expliquer vous cette espèce de
désinvolture dans la première semaine du
du conflit comment alors facile à dire
assis tranquillement sur son fauteuil
comment ils ont pas vu venir ce parce
que il y a des connaisseurs
de
l'environnement social vous nous
décriviez un secteur qui est plus
indiqué que les autres bref la capacité
de blocage il y avait deux trois
éléments qui pouvaient les alerter alors
sur un plan plus générale moi je suis un
peu frappé en fait je crois qu'ils sont
assez prisonniers de leur dogme qui
consiste à dire on va protéger les
entreprises on ne va surtout pas leur
charger là-bas donc fiscale ou autre
parce que c'est le cœur battant du pays
pour repartir de l'avant etc c'est
vraiment dans cette question cruciale et
en fait c'est c'est sur ça que porte ce
conflit donc de la part du partage des
richesses on voit bien qu'ils sont
empêtrés là-dedans parce que ils ont
quand même toutes les peines du monde à
dissiper l'idée que qu'on a qu'il met
toute la pression nécessaire sur les
entreprises du secteur des langues
arbures et notamment de total pour que à
défaut d'être taxé ces entreprises
précisément redistribuent donc c'est
bien de ça dont il s'agit c'est que au
total tarde à redistribué et ça peut
être un élément effectivement de la de
l'équation c'est à dire que on a
aujourd'hui par la bouche Olivier avant
que le gouvernement souhaitait demander
à total de prolonger la ristourne à la
pompe donc peut-être qu'ils se sont dit
on va on peut pas leur taper
continuellement sur la tête je mets des
guillemets à tout ça franchement on est
dans un contexte parfaitement
extraordinaire on parlait mobilisation
sociale là tout est réuni enfin vraiment
pour que effectivement le torchon brûle
la France comme le disait la France
insoumise et là pour le coup ils avaient
raison
ne n'avancez pas sur cette idée de taxes
sur les supers profits d'un secteur
pétrolier qui en effet est là et on
parlait d'économie de la rente si c'est
pas une économie de la rente là on se
demande ce que c'est donc la France ne
réagissait pas alors que l'Espagne
l'Italie le Royaume-Uni taxait donc
finalement ils finissent par réagir en
annonçant deux amendements au projet de
loi de finances mais dans le cadre
européen d'une contribution
extraordinaire temporaire sur le secteur
les entreprises du pétrole du charbon du
gaz etc donc finissent par à réagir mais
c'est vrai qu'on les sent enfin
j'interprète ça comme ça si vous voulez
d'un point de vue plus large on laissait
en fait pris dans cette contradiction
c'est à dire que je pense qu'il mesure
très bien effectivement ce qui est en
jeu et en même temps ils ne veulent pas
entraver ces entreprises mais enfin
quand il s'agit de Total moi je veux
bien comprendre sur des entreprises des
petites entreprises et des moyennes
entreprises le partage de la richesse ça
peut être très compliqué surtout dans un
secteur dans un dans une époque où
l'énergie coûte cher enfin totale comme
on le rappelait à l'instant c'est quand
même total ils ont eu un solide pour
pouvoir redistribuer donc je pense que
là et c'est à mon avis là alors grande
erreur franchement de d'analyse c'est
qu'ils n'ont pas perçu que ce mouvement
il peut être lu d'ailleurs dans un dans
une dans un deuxième temps comme une
colère qui qui trouve les mauvais canaux
pour s'exprimer à mon sens puisqu'elle
pénalise tous les Français et les plus
modestes notamment mais qui est une
colère absolument légitime et qui n'a
pas trouvé de réponse en fait et cette
colère là ça a vraiment ça exige qu'on
pense davantage à comment on va
contraindre ce qu'ils le peuvent à
effectivement répartir le fruit de leur
activité alors vouliez tous les deux
réagir je vais d'abord donner la parole
à Benjamin Morel ensuite c'est ma boucle
des réponses assez rapides parce qu'il y
a encore beaucoup de thèmes à aborder
rapidement je crois qu'il y a également
une crainte d'un risque de contagion
c'est à dire que grosso modo aujourd'hui
vous avez des entreprises qui peuvent se
le permettre visiblement total a priori
peut se permettre d'augmenter les
salaires vous avez beaucoup
d'entreprises qui ne peuvent pas se le
permettre et vous avez une politique qui
plus est du gouvernement qui est une
politique aujourd'hui d'être activité on
a beaucoup d'inflation mais on a
également des salaires qui ne suivent
pas regardez ce qui se passe en Belgique
vous avez des traitements des
fonctionnaires notamment qui sont
indexés sur l'inflation en France n'est
pas le cas donc ce faisant si jamais
vous ne bougez pas trop les salaires et
bien vous devenez plus attractif ça
c'est une politique qui est une
politique de long terme d'Emmanuel
Macron fondamentalement si jamais vous
avez une hausse globale des salaires
parce que vous avez une multiplication
des conflits sociaux ça signifie
d'augmenter les fonctionnaires ou ça
signifie de soute et ça signifie de
soutenir des entreprises qui ne peuvent
pas à elle seule aider aujourd'hui leurs
salariés en montant les salaires ça
signifie quoi
cela signifie plus de dettes or vous
voyez aujourd'hui que et à Berlin et à
Bruxelles et notamment également à la
BCE qui change sa politique on est en
train de froncer les sourcils donc là il
y a un sujet qui n'est pas qu'un sujet
je dirais sectoriel qui est également un
sujet macroéconomique si ma boule il y a
aussi un rapport de force qui est
intéressant quoi et qui explique le fait
que la CGT rejoindre par défaut on l'a
dit mais soit dans dans cette stratégie
là on l'a évoqué le fait que la CGT
essaye d'étendre le mouvement à
certaines centrales nucléaires il y a
cinq réacteurs nucléaires qui sont
maintenant et où les travaux sont
arrêtés aujourd'hui parce que la CGT
n'en su une grève il y a cette notion là
de position de force dans ces secteurs
là dans un contexte de crise énergétique
d'action c'est-à-dire quand vous êtes
salarié vous n'avez pas finalement
beaucoup d'armes si vous dites juste je
vais écrire un track je vais protester
je vais faire négociation il y a de
fortes chances que on vous dites très
bien merci au revoir là enfin ce qui est
peut-être gagné pour la CGT alors
peut-être pas la bataille de l'opinion
publique pour l'instant mais en tous les
cas ce qu'ils ont gagné et ce qui semble
avoir réussi c'est de médiatiser leur le
conflit social puisque ça fait la une de
tous les autres depuis plusieurs jours
c'était peut-être un des objectifs et ça
je vais vous dire à quel prix quand même
c'est toujours la même chose c'est quand
vous avez des négociations qui sont dans
des salons feutrés personne n'en parle
et s'il y a échec pour les salariés bah
c'est vous prenez tous les conflits puis
plusieurs décennies enfin plus plusieurs
années au minimum c'est un échec pour
les salariés et puis on apprend quand
c'est dans une entreprise privée qui a
un plan de licenciement que 300 400 500
salariés vont se retrouver au chômage
parce qu'il y a pas une il n'y a pas eu
d'action publique le principe de ce que
les syndicalistes appelaient l'action
directe au 19e siècle et enfin la fin du
19e siècle et au début du 20e siècle
c'est justement de d'agir beaucoup plus
directement et deux médiatiser enfin on
parlait pas de médiatisation mais de
faire reconnaître l'importance de leurs
causes et l'intérêt de leur cause et là
on exactement dans cette dans cette
position là donc après la balle est
aussi dans le camp des pouvoirs publics
en disant et des entreprises en disant
qu'est-ce que vous voulez on se remet
autour de la table en négocie puisque on
est face à des coûts et que on sait où
comment et dernière chose quand on est
dans un mouvement social
de cette nature là avec derrière une
crise en toile de fond qui qui est
présente on fait plus attention parce
que on sait comment ça commence mais on
sait absolument jamais comment ça peut
se terminer je rappelle mai 68 il y
avait une toute petite grève à Sud
Aviation à Saint-Nazaire ça a donné 10
millions de grévistes quelques semaines
après comme on est quand même aussi dans
un phénomène alors de crise mais de
reprise économique c'est pas du tout ce
qui peut se passer dans les
si la difficulté à la ligne de crête sur
laquelle le gouvernement peut se trouver
depuis quelques jours pour savoir s'il
pense plutôt vers le côté Ré position
usage de la force ou vers le côté
laissant la place à la négociation on va
parler des des réactions politiques
évidemment il y en a beaucoup bonsoir
Quentin quand un calmé qui vous rejoint
va nourrit les questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement cet après-midi ici au Sénat
exactement j'entendais votre débat en
plateau ça faisait vraiment écho avec ce
qui s'est passé dans l'hémicycle du
Sénat cet après-midi vous allez le voir
c'est beaucoup sur le thème des super
profits de Total les communistes qui ont
ainsi dénoncé les milliards d'euros de
bénéfices de en 2022 sur le dos en plus
selon eux du bouclier tarifaire mis en
place par l'État écoutez la prise de
parole en extrait en tout cas la prise
de parole d'Éric boquait tout à l'heure
les salariés des groupes pétroliers
demandent légitimement leur part de
cette réussite entre guillemets et
revendique une hausse de leur salaire la
satisfaction des revendications des
salariés pour Total énergie
représenterait une somme de 140 millions
d'euros soit 1,4 % des profits du sol
premier semestre et le sénateur donc de
demander au gouvernement de faire
pression sur la direction de Total autre
prise de parole sur ce thème des super
profits et de la grève chez Total avec
celle de Patrick hanère le chef de fil
des sénateurs socialistes au Sénat et
qui a réclamé deos général des salaires
en France face à l'inflation une
proposition que les socialistes a-t-il
dit font au gouvernement depuis le mois
de juillet écoutez Patrick canard
voulez-vous faire comprendre à les
salariés de Total qui demande une
revalorisation de 10% 7% pour
l'inflation 3% pour les profils de
l'entreprise que leur patron monsieur
pouyanet a augmenté de 52% son salaire
en 2021 pour atteindre 500000 € par mois
voilà ce qui est un juste et vous ne le
combattez pas vous êtes faible avec les
forts et fort avec les faibles alors on
va donner un peu la parole du coup à
l'exécutif la première ministre elle qui
a inventé son bilan parlant par exemple
de la hausse du SMIC revalorisé de plus
8% pour l'année 2022 qu'à la comparé à
l'inflation de 6% elle a également salué
les plus de 500 accords de branches déjà
signé depuis le début de l'année 2022
écoutez un autre extrait de sa réponse
je suis d'accord toutes les entreprises
qui le peuvent doivent augmenter les
salaires à fortiori dans la période
d'inflation que nous connaissons mais
monsieur le Président Kanner je sais que
vous le savez c'est du dialogue social
que viendra la réponse le dialogue
social j'y crois prof forcément mais le
dialogue social c'est se mettre autour
de la table c'est respecté les accords
majoritaires c'est chercher des
compromis ça n'est pas bloqué le pays
voilà on le voit Thomas le point de
départ c'était bien total mais ce que
les sénateurs de gauche ont voulu mettre
comme débat sur la place publique c'est
bien la question des salaires pour tous
merci Quentin j'aurais qu'on parle de
effectivement du du risque ou de la
possibilité de de d'une extension de ce
mouvement risque d'embrasement social
dit certains on a parlé de des travaux
bloqués travaux de maintenance dans cinq
réacteurs
nucléaires
est-ce que ça aussi
claire Chartier vous mettez ça dans le
même sac c'est vous disiez est-ce que
cette grève est justifiée est-ce qu'elle
est responsable
voilà on est dans un contexte de de
crise énergétique avec un enjeu de
passer l'hiver l'expression qu'on
emploie depuis des semaines évitez les
coupures de d'électricité est-ce que
c'est le moment de lancer cette grève
est assez complexe parce que en effet on
se dit je crois enfin moi je n'ai pas
souvenir d'avoir ressenti la société
française aussi tendue aussi crispé
depuis que je travaille comme
journaliste franchement je n'ai jamais
connu cette période comme celle-là donc
c'est vrai que on se dit rajouter en
plus cette difficulté là même si encore
une fois la cause est parfaitement
justifiée alors en plus vous parlez du
nucléaire là c'est autrement symbolique
c'est que on sait très bien que toute la
stratégie enfin la survie énergétique
elle repose sur ces fameux réacteurs qui
faut remettre en route donc maintenant
quand on apprend en plus que il vaut
peut-être pas se remettre en route au
moment où il faut là c'est vrai que ça a
de quoi vraiment démoralisé très
profondément le pays et c'est vrai
j'avoue je trouve que c'est il y a une
part de il y a quelque chose qui me
dérange là parce qu'on a tellement de
mal à faire face à l'adversité
aujourd'hui que que ça s'enchaîne de
cette manière là je ne sais pas de
quelle façon finalement ça peut être
constructif pour le pays voilà c'est
c'est juste je rejoins assez l'idée que
un dialogue social c'est un dialogue
social et qu'effectivement il faut des
leviers mais que
ça doit pouvoir cette question des
salaires se parler se discuter par
effectivement par des moyens qui soient
encore une fois plus constructif pour la
collectivité mais on l'a déjà dit sur ce
plateau avec vous d'ailleurs s'il va
vouloir et vous l'avez rappelé
on dit souvent la CFDT syndicat
réformiste on a on a de nouveau employé
cette expression et localement soit dans
des accords de branches soit dans des
entreprises la CGT signent beaucoup de
d'accord avec le avec le patronat donc
est-ce que je vous posais la même
question que la dernière fois parce que
j'ai tellement cette impression et
j'avoue que ça bagasse moi l'impression
qu'il y a deux attitudes presque une
posture nationale où on est dans des
enjeux il faut montrer qu'on a un
syndicat dur qui négocie pas et qui et
qui signe aucun accord et puis
localement on enseigne plein elle est où
la cohérence de ce syndicat dans ce
cas-là en fait l'histoire du
syndicalisme alors je vais très essayer
d'être très très bref il y a plusieurs
choses tout syndicat donc localement je
parle pas des confédérations syndicales
syndicat localement et par définition
référence puisque son objectif est de
défendre des intérêts matériels et
moraux de ces salariés donc à partir de
ce moment-là il y a un moment où il
faudra négocier avec l'entrepreneur
deuxième chose le raisin les logiques en
train de repreneuriat et le jeu salarial
sont pas les mêmes en d'autres termes ça
s'appelle le conflit entre le capital et
le travail ou comme disait et moi à
Rouen pour prendre un
ibéral ça s'appelle aussi la lutte des
classes puisque ben on a deux groupes
antagonistes qui vont s'affronter après
on a une histoire syndicale sur lequel
on n'a pas le temps de revenir
aujourd'hui qui est effectivement il y a
des postures qui sont différentes si
vous êtes c'est des tistes tous ces
gétistes donc la CFDT ou à la à la CGT
cela étant quand on regarde localement
on retrouve cette tradition syndicale
qui est de négociation alors après
effectivement on a des appareils au
niveau national qui sont sur des sur des
positions relativement différentes mais
il faut faire attention à certaines
choses c'est que ces positions elles
peuvent évoluer d'un moment à un autre
sur les retraites là on a pour l'instant
un unanimisme dans le refus de toute de
tout recul de l'âge de retraite donc ça
va dépendre de la façon dont les
différentes centrales syndicales on
pensait les évolutions de la société
française dans les depuis les décennies
pas la part de responsabilité de ce
gouvernement pardon nous interrogations
de ce gouvernement Mathieu l'a évoqué
d'autres gouvernements auparavant je
sous-estime pas la part de
responsabilité du patronat et et du
Medef mais pourquoi on n'arrive pas à
faire au niveau national ce qu'on arrive
à faire localement pardon de poser une
question très basique mais je n'arrive
pas à le comprendre mais en fait ça
existe c'est juste qu'on est plus
interpellé dès qu'il y a des
mobilisations sociales c'est-à-dire
quand le pays est plus ou moins paralysé
on se rend compte à la CGT est plus
actif parce que c'est aussi une
tradition une histoire une histoire
syndicale qui est différente de celle de
la CFDT qui depuis une vingtaine
d'années a préféré les négociations dans
des dans des salons plutôt que plutôt
que l'action l'action publique après
c'est des choses qui peuvent évoluer il
y a 40 ans là CFDT était beaucoup plus
revendicative on retrouvait les
sénatistes dans les luttes sociales dans
les conflits sociaux jusqu'à ce qu'ils
soient cessé de la CFDT et fondent font
de se dire enfin les sud puis solidaire
donc il y a des histoires syndicales qui
se mêlent entre croisent pour l'instant
on est sur ce schéma là ça veut pas dire
forcément que ça reste ce schéma là je
vous rappelle que Laurent Berger là au
dernier congrès est obligé de faire un
certain nombre de propositions beaucoup
plus offensive que celle qui est
habituée à faire parce que la les autres
militants de la CFDT sont dans une
posture beaucoup plus revendicatrices et
beaucoup plus revendicatif par rapport à
ce qui est en train de se passer au
niveau de au niveau national il nous
reste deux minutes dans ce débat
Benjamin rapidement je rejoins tout à
fait ce qui a été dit il faut voir que
d'abord il y a bientôt des élections
professionnelles ça compte deuxième
élément vous avez une base qui
aujourd'hui est beaucoup plus radicale
que le sommet
une nécessité pour ces syndicats s'il
veut être représentatifs d'être
également dans une position de
radicalité dans une période qui est une
période en effet extrêmement difficile
et extrêmement dangereuse je rappelle
que pour l'instant l'opinion selon les
derniers sondages est assez partagé il y
a 40 % qui sont favorables à grève 42%
des favorable ou l'inverse enfin bref ça
se joue dans un mouchoir de poche merci
beaucoup à tous les trois d'avoir
participé à ce débat Sylvain boulot que
je rappelle le titre de votre livre le
peuple du drapeau noir une histoire des
anarchistes publiés aux éditions
Atlant de